[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and in march
we finally answer the question of what's
a king to a god
godzilla versus kong is finally set to
release and warner bros have really
started
upping the marketing of the movie with
some legendary trailers and tv spots
this video we're going to be breaking
down some of the biggest questions
surrounding the movie
it's runtime the easter eggs things you
missed
and what we think is really going on
some spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined then i
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you blah blah blah the thumbs
up button and blah blah blah subscribe
to blah blah blah blah
with out of the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
video
okay so the first thing i want to talk
about is the movies runtime
according to google the film will be
weighing in at a hefty 2 hours and 52
minutes
making it the mightiest monster movie of
all time
now i have to say that this isn't 100
confirmed yet
and google doesn't always get things
spot on when it comes to movie
information
so it may be subject to change early
screenings of the film
actually came in under two hours but as
they happened almost two years ago
things could have changed due to
legendary having a lot more time to work
on the film
it was revealed earlier in the week by
the film's composer junkie xl
that the aircraft carrier scene runs for
a whopping 18 minutes
so it is possible that due to the delays
that the vfx artist
actually added more meat to the movie
and increased the action scenes as
they're what everyone wants to see
what you mean it's two and a half hours
of human drama
oh no anyway this is awesome i think and
it also looks like the movie is going to
be fights over feelings
which i feel the movies so far have been
lacking
big monster is where it's at so let them
fight
and give us three hours of pure fan
service please
now speaking of the marketing there's a
lot of tv spots dropping at the moment
and it seems like every single day that
we're seeing more and more of the movie
i actually wish they would kind of hold
off on this as they are spoiling a bit
too much
and i know that's rich coming from me
but i do want some surprises
you know i just like a surprise now and
then however these new looks have
brought a lot of new questions with them
and we're going to be trying to answer
them to the best of our ability
now the first big one is why does it
look like kong is stuck in the hex at
one point
in the build up to this scene he grabs a
tree and strips it of his branches
which then turns into a deadly javelin
that he holds at the sky
revealing a force field in the process
no it's not kong division
it's actually something else and what's
happened is that kong has been captured
at this point in the movie
and placed into a containment facility
humanity knows that one of the best
weapons that we have against the titans
is our ability to trick them and thus
they've created a huge truman show-esque
dome that spans miles and miles
in it there's an abundance of
holographic technology that can be used
to mimic any environment
and the vegetation within has also been
adapted to fit the look of skull
island so that kong doesn't believe that
he's been captured
we actually see the outside of this in
the trailer and it looks like it might
be at the moment that kong throws the
tree against the barrier
that we too get the reveal that he's
encased in it as for the purpose of it i
think that this is so that they can
better study him
and who knows it might even be set up by
apex so that they can replicate the
character
we already know that they have built
mechagodzilla and thus this could be
somewhat of a lab to study kong
and potentially clone him up i know i
know that's a bit of a long shot yeah
and i i am reaching right now
and it could also be set up simply as a
way to control his behavior and keep him
occupied
whilst they wait for godzilla to attack
once more it feels very pacific rim to
me due to the technological advancements
that they've made since the last couple
of movies
and who knows you might even be in a
simulation right now mate
and there's also been released what
looks like it could be kong getting
carried across the earth by an amara of
helicarriers
in one of the tv spots we can see kong
lying in a giant net
whilst being flown somewhere snowy
during it the cables on the airplane
snap
and we then cut to him waking up in the
ice and because of this i can actually
see this being
later in the movie rather than it being
the scene when they left him out of
skull island
whilst we don't know what this snowy
environment is
it could be the cave that chronicles the
battles between the gajira and kong
or the place that at least gives us
information on their history
in the build-up to the trailer's release
we did get a cave painting that
looks like it might have been the
world's first spoiler
and this very much prophesized their
battle i feel like
in the movie kong is gonna sort of be
our eyes and ears as we discover the
history and battles that the species
have had over the millennia
and this is why he finds the hand print
and we can also see what looks like a
gajira outline
and that might be wrong but from all the
leaks i've looked over they've never
actually mentioned how these two scenes
tie together
and i think it just makes far more of a
driving force for kong to actually get a
motive to why he has to fight godzilla
rather than just having the humans
pointing the pair at one another
the moment itself also is an homage to
the original
in which kong was carried across the sky
with giant balloons
and though that though that scene's not
it doesn't hold up let's be honest
it's nice that they've kind of updated
it and there was also a clip released by
ign on friday
after they had an interview with the
movies director adam wingard
i did have this in my tv spot
compilation but ign asked me to remove
it because
it was their exclusive which which is
fair enough and they probably didn't
want other channels just taking their
views for an upload
that's why the last video we posted on
the movie is now missing a large chunk
and i know most of you don't care i just
thought i'd clear up why why that's
happened
now they did say i was allowed to do a
commentary on it but i'm just leaving
the watermark in
so there's no hard feelings now the clip
opens with the f-35 lightning 2 which
you might recognize from king of the
monsters as the aircraft that was used
to fight against rodan
the jets are attacking godzilla as he
swims in to take kong on and
clearly at this point the humans know
that something is off with him
as he's been attacking cities and so on
therefore they aren't taking any chances
and they bombard him with missiles which
is when the tail attacks one of the jets
we also see some amazing underwater
shots and wingard told ign that the new
clip is heavily influenced by the movie
jaws
this is of course a classic and godzilla
swims through the sea
almost like a shark as he makes his way
towards his target whilst
kong looks down into the water unable to
see when or where he's coming from
there's also his fin which pops up on
the surface much in the same way that a
shark does
making for a cool little callback as
mentioned earlier the jet is smashed by
godzilla's tail
and ships start closing in on him which
is when it also takes out two of them in
one fell swoop
an anchor then attaches onto godzilla
and he drags half its hole down to the
bottom of the ocean
which i think might also be similar to
how jaws did something with the dock
though that might be a reach it could
also be similar the barrel scene as we
see this part of the ship pop up later
on
and either way it's nice that they're
paying tribute to one of the best movies
of all time
now you can also catch people coming out
of the caucus of the ship and i hope
them lads have been taking swimming
lessons
because it's a long way up sticking with
the jaws callbacks
this could be similar to the story of
the uss indianapolis
which quinn describes in one of the
film's best scenes
the boat was sunk and the sailors that
survived were picked off by the sharks
over a number of days
it's a horrifying real life story and
knowing that the people who survived
this attack
could be stuck in the water adds a lot
more to this scene
next we see kong trying to pull on the
chains of the ship because he's captive
but he's unable to yank them loose this
is likely because of the tanks on his
collar that we pointed out in our last
trailer breakdown
which potentially contain a sedative
thus kong might actually get his ass
kicked
if he's been drugged during this and
this could be why the humans eventually
decide to use simulations to keep him
calm
rather than the drugs anyway i can't
wait to see the movie and with it
releasing in 30 days time
it's awesome that march is gonna be a
big month for the monster this
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the new tv spots
whether you think they're showing too
much or if you want to keep seeing more
and more
with it being three hours long i almost
feel like there's a lot they still have
to show us
but of course let me know below if you
want some big surprises still
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
on the 31st of march and which we're
giving away three copies of a marvel 4k
boxer of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the tv spots the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
one division episode 8 which will be
linked on screen right now
we've gone over the episode from top to
bottom and pointed out all the cool
little easter eggs so it's definitely
worth watching
if if you're bored as hell without the
way thank you for sitting through the
video
i mean paul i'll see you next time take
care peace